from summit with Kim jong-un completely
fizzled were you disappointed about that
were you upset about that let me ask you
another question did you even know about
it how did you know about the summit
good I'm just gonna talk to you okay no
one else here it knows what the hell's
going on these Millennials don't get the
newspaper no it was the whole thing
fizzled yeah people are talking about
they can't figure out and people say
that these summit had a lot of problems
some people complained this is true that
it was a problem not a lot of reporters
were allowed to cover the summit in
Vietnam they didn't allow a lot of
reporters to even go there
yeah it was so restricted the only
journalists from the US was Mario Lopez
he story yeah that's - he got a Pulitzer
Prize for it after the deal fell apart
this is the quote Trump said sometimes
you have to walk yes so now his Fitbit
is up to 14 steps
thank you notice things are real floppy
when he walks around have you noticed
that yeah he's just his job long time
long time ajayan tent-like jacket
sometimes you go to walk slop slop slop
no one can agree on why the summit ended
kim jungeun is saying one thing
president trouble saying another I don't
know who to believe the crazy haired
chubby dictator who barely speaks
English or Kim jong-un
we I don't know you but I have an
incredible connection with you right now